[Música]
hola a todos
estoy muy entusiasmada por estar aquí el
día de hoy quisiera comenzar platicando
les un poema de gregorio marañón que
dice
vivir no es solo existir
si no existir y crear
saber gozar y sufrir y no dormir sin
soñar descansar es empezar a morir
algunos de ustedes se ha preguntado que
trascendentales están siendo en su paso
por esta vida
en su paso por este planeta
estamos dejando huella con los que
conocemos o simplemente estamos
existiendo como dice el poema
solo estamos pasando por los años
existiendo
cuando nosotros empezamos a crecer
siempre en las personas nos dicen cuál
es tu propósito de esta vida qué es lo
que buscas de esta vida
para muchos esa idea resulta aterradora
porque dicen ya estoy por cumplir 30 40
50 años y no tengo ni la menor idea
entonces pues mejor descarto de que
pudiera yo tener algún propósito
algunos otros tal vez si tienen una vaga
idea de cuál pudiera ser su propósito
pero qué flojera no es un poco
complicado tengo que hacer muchas cosas
estoy más cómodo así como estoy fue a la
universidad todos los días tomo clases
fue mi casa o tengo un trabajo estable
en mi trabajo pues estoy contento soy
feliz para que todo eso del propósito y
me esfuerzo demasiado
usted es aquel grupo de personas
pertenecen
en ocasiones llegamos a confundir este
término y hay dos puntos super
importantes que me gustaría que tomen en
cuenta con todo esto la trascendencia
el primero es han de estar pensando
bueno trascender a ver hitler o nicolás
maduro ellos qué
este tipo de personas no trascienden
este tipo de personas únicamente pasan a
la historia por sus acciones de maldad
y vamos a hablar de otro punto
importante han de estar pensando bueno
pues es que si no soy famoso en mi país
o si no soy famoso en el mundo o por lo
menos en mi ciudad pues estoy
trascendiendo porque nadie me conoce no
estoy dejando huella
aquí trascender puede ser con una
persona con un familiar con un amigo con
un conocido o desconocido eso no importa
nosotros trascendemos cuando
sobrevivimos más allá de la muerte
cuando hacemos las cosas con el corazón
cuando hacemos las cosas con pasión
cuando realmente nos hace vibrar eso que
estamos haciendo y lo transmitimos a las
personas
y no nada más eso contagiamos ese
progreso contagiamos y explotamos ese
potencial en otros
a través de nuestras acciones y a través
de lo que vamos generando
ya las diapositivas me las pasé que es
si nosotros buscamos en un diccionario
que nos dice sobre trascender
empezar a ser conocidos en algo que
estaba oculto o hacer que algo tenga un
efecto en un lugar diferente en el que
se produjo hacer un cambio tener algún
tipo de crecimiento no eso es lo que
nosotros vemos en el diccionario
el mundo entero se aparta
cuando ve pasar a un nombre que sabe a
dónde va
esta es una frase que me encanta porque
una vez que nosotros tenemos claro qué
es lo que queremos hacer claro a dónde
queremos llegar
aunque durante el camino durante el
proceso esa meta vaya cambiando no
importa las personas estamos en
constante cambio todo el tiempo y no es
necesario que tengamos una idea desde
que tenemos 15 años y que esa idea se
quede hasta el momento de nuestra muerte
pero cuando nosotros tenemos las ideas
fijas es mucho más fácil que los caminos
se vayan abriendo no digo que sea fácil
no digo que no haya tropiezos no digo
que no haya puntos complicados
de todas aquellas cosas que ustedes
hagan en la vida únicamente serán
memorables las que hagan con el corazón
y para eso me gustaría darles dos
ejemplos dos historias son historias
reales las dos sobre historias de
trascendencia sobre ejemplos para que
entiendan un poquito más acerca lo que
les estoy hablando del tipo de
trascendencia del que les estoy hablando
la primera historia
yo soy de la ciudad de córdoba veracruz
y cuando era chiquita iba a casa de mi
abuela en las tardes
y lo más divertido de estar en su casa
en las tardes ella vivía en una privada
era cuando a lo lejos escuchábamos
elotes
el hotel
era don juan' él era un señor alto de
bigote de unos 55 años aproximadamente
él tiene una manera tan apasionante de
vender elotes
lo hacía con tantas ganas con tanto
esfuerzo y con tanto corazón
que yo hoy les puedo decir que él por lo
menos deja una huella en mi vida
no sabemos que ha sido su vida después
pero yo les puedo decir que él dejó
huella es decir por qué
el en su carrito trae un globo terráqueo
todos a una locación luego terminó
entonces en cuanto llegaba a todos nos
forma vamos y tenían una latita con unos
palitos que tenían un color pintado en
la punta entonces tú sacabas un palito y
te tocaba el verde entonces le daba la
vuelta al mapa mundi y lo paraba y te
decía dónde está el monte everest aquí
aquí aquí o aquí teníamos siete años
nosotros digamos el monte que y si te
tocaba azul
cuál es el río nilo este este este oeste
donde está portugal aquí y aquí de
acuerdo al color que te tocaba
como les explicó obviamente hace 20 años
no existía ni google ni internet ni nada
de eso entonces lo esperábamos con un
mapamundi cee en la mano para buscar la
respuesta porque si la teníamos bien que
creemos
pues era el dos por uno no recordaba a
otro
en una fila de niños porque era una
privada donde vivíamos varios varios
vecinos que ya lo esperábamos con ansias
este señor evidentemente su pasión era
la geografía
y evidentemente no tuvo los recursos
para trabajar en algo que tuviera que
ver con lo que le apasionaba
entonces qué fue lo que hizo busco en su
realidad y en su día a día cómo dejar
huella cómo marcar y cómo explotar ese
potencial que él tenía apagado
no sé qué de su vida pero esta misma
historia la platica en una conferencia
hace como tres años eran como 500
personas y una persona al público mi
hijo yo también soy de cordoba y yo
también me acuerdo del del otero
digo pero es una chiquita tendrá
trescientos cincuenta mil habitantes
pero por lo menos que un pequeño grupo
nos hayamos quedado con sus ideas con
sus lecciones por comprar esquites o por
comprar elotes
créanme que eso es dejar huella
les voy a cantar la segunda historia
este es un documental sobre la vida real
de un concurso de shorts jon de
filmaciones cortas que fue en el
festival internacional de cannes ya
tiene como 10 años más o menos este
video se llama chicana la carta
al principio el vídeo aparece en
muchísimos lugares de comida rápida por
ejemplo mcdonald's burger king intento
que practiquen piercings el que se lo
den a la mente no cause juniors aparecen
todos logotipos y vamos a la gente súper
feliz formada pidiendo hay hamburguesa
papas nudos o lo que fueran a comer los
niños jugando otros en las mesas de
todos alguna vez mostrado en donalds no
sabemos cómo es esa convivencia
después se hace de noche cierra el
rostro cierra un restaurant se va toda
la gente y aparece un señor
por la parte trasera del restaurante en
una bicicleta de esas que tienen como
una canasta grande adelante ya saben
cuáles tres amarillas llevan su
bicicleta
y toca la puerta
le abren y el del restaurant le se pasa
le señaló una esquina el baix esquina
y de un bote de basura saca todo lo que
estaba en la bolsa y empieza a separar
por aquí las sobras de comida por aquí
servilleta papel desechables aquí
tantito apoyo aquí sobre tantito pan
otra hamburgo otra servilleta y empieza
a secar separar las obras de la basura
al siguiente día aparece este mismo
señor llegando en su bicicleta con el
bote de lo que había recolectado
a una comunidad muy muy poco con suelo
de tierra con casas de madera zelaya
deben imaginar perfecto cómo era
en ese momento se escuchan los gritos y
el ruido de diez o quince niños que
llegan a su alrededor a rodearlo y
aplaudir ya gritar de la emoción
porque sus comidas de ese día había
llegado
ellos agarran la bolsa la empiezan a
abrir y le empiezan a comer
con una emoción con un ánimo con una
felicidad porque ese señor había hecho
algo por ellos
quién sabe cuántos días llevaban cinco
meses
en la noche el señor llega a su casa
había guardado una pequeña bolsa de más
comida
igual una casa muy humilde y la abre
empieza a repartir a sus cuatro hijos ya
su esposa un cachito a ti otro pedacito
a ti otro a ti
pero antes de empezar a cenar
todos se presionaron para dar las
gracias por la cena ese día
son dos historias
que para muchos estos dos personajes
tanto el elotero como el señor del
documental pues no salieron en ningún
periódico
tampoco tuvieron reconocimientos
nadie les dio una medalla
pero si les puedo decir que ellos
dejaron huella
que ellos supieron cuál era su misión en
ese momento qué era lo que necesitaban
hacer para explotar ese potencial y lo
alcanzaron
aquí nosotros tenemos un gran reto
porque la mayoría si no es que todos de
los que estamos en este auditorio aquí
presentes hemos tenido muchísimas
oportunidades
tal vez unos más unos menos tal vez unos
más dificultades' otros menos pero por
lo menos hoy tuve la oportunidad y
tuvieron el dinero para pagar un boleto
para estar intactos
me imagino que saliendo aquí tienen un
techo donde dormir y tienen algo para
poder cenar
que estamos haciendo para dejar huella y
trascender en los que más nos quieren
trascender con aquellas personas que
coincidimos en la vida
con aquellas personas que nos topamos en
la vida por lo menos unos instantes unos
minutos
no les estoy hablando que necesito que
se vuelvan el próximo presidente de
méxico
o tampoco que se vuelvan el mejor
futbolista del mundo y tengan un millón
de seguidores en su cuenta de instagram
se ha llegado a confundir mucho este
término tiene muchos seguidores con es
una buena persona
hace rato en una de las conferencias que
hicieron me gustó muchísimo que los
youtubers están haciendo algo diferente
con ese potencial que tienen para
cambiar el mundo
y qué están haciendo ustedes
le estoy moviendo sin darme cuenta
perdona
con los que más queremos con nuestra
familia con nuestros amigos
les voy a hacer unas preguntas de
autorreflexión
alguna vez alguien se ha acercado a
ustedes y les ha dado las gracias por
algo que ustedes dieron por ellos
alguna vez algún amigo que ha estado en
algún problema y usted lo han apoyado
o tal vez apoyando alguna ong
o no precisamente algo altruista
porque no en un negocio en un
emprendimiento como decía él viste hace
rato no porque estemos generando dinero
quiere decir que no estamos apoyando
trascendiendo o haciendo algún efecto
positivo
hay empresas o hay empresarios o hay
líderes o hay gerentes que tienen gran
responsabilidad social y se preocupan
por las personas y dejen realmente una
huella en las personas que conocen y que
ven que tratan todos los días
hace unas semanas estuve de viaje y en
el aeropuerto me encontré con un libro
maravilloso que se llama la inteligencia
del éxito de ancho pérez él es un chavo
español un acuerdo que en lugar de
españa es pero él es un emprendedor
tiene 29 30 años habla siete idiomas
ha trabajado en la onu ha trabajado en
el fbi ha recibido premios
internacionales de emprendimiento y
aparte desarrolló una metodología que se
llama eight build como de ocho
cinturones donde aprendes cualquier
idioma en 7 m en 8 meses es la propuesta
de aprender cualquier idioma en 8 meses
entonces él en uno de sus en uno de los
capítulos de su libro menciona que
cuando nosotros hacemos algo bueno por
alguien tú llegas y no perdón cuál es tu
nombre si él hoy por ejemplo yo algo
hago algo bueno por ti eloy y tú me
dices cómo te lo puedo pagar y aquí lo
que has hecho por mí con otro para pagar
como tiene que ser las respuestas de
ustedes
el menciona el pay forward
de acuerdo les voy a explicar en inglés
el término playback es regresar es decir
yo hago algo por ti y tú me lo pagas con
algún otro favor o como sea de acuerdo
pero si nosotros pagamos hey forward es
decir yo hago algo por ti pero tú lo
pagas hacia adelante alguien más como
una cadena de favores
con todo esto es lo que me gustaría que
saquemos del día de hoy siempre cuando
vamos a alguna conferencia alguna
plática algún evento de estos tenemos
que llevarnos algo algo que poder
compartir algo que poder transmitir a
las demás personas
y eso es con lo que quiero que se quede
punto número uno
el dejar huella no preocuparnos tal vez
por el mundo entero porque no lo vamos a
lograr en nuestro en nuestra realidad y
no porque algo que no se pueda sino
porque hay que ser realistas a veces no
quiero hacer algo por todo el mundo
bueno pero ahorita como estas por quien
puedes hacer algo o con quienes puedes
dejar huella pues por ellos hazlo país
que yo trabajo en una oficina de 8 a 2 y
de 4 a 7 estoy que voy a hacer algo
igual gimnasio mis hijos y sano y me
duermo y que tanto puedo hacer una
oficina
aunque tanto puedo hacer en mi salón de
clases
acuérdense del otero que tanto puede
hacer con el otero
es lo mismo y como punto número 2
safe for work es decir cuando ustedes
hagan algo por alguien y alguien se lo
quiera recompensar como lo hacemos paga
hacia adelante
me encantan los poemas y las frases y
los pensamientos porque no nada más es
algo bonito para postear o compartir
sino realmente tienen un aprendizaje hay
uno que es de francisco luis bernárdez
con el que quisiera terminar que dice
si para recobrar lo recobrado debí
perder primero lo perdido
si para conseguir lo conseguido tuve que
soportar lo soportado
si para estar ahora enamorado fue
menester estar primero herido
teniendo por bien tenido lo tenido tengo
por bien sus perdones teniendo por bien
tenido lo tenido tengo por bien sufrido
los llorado porque después de todo he
aprendido que no se sabían de lo gozado
sino después de haberlo padecido
porque después de todo he comprendido
que el árbol tiene de florido lo que
tiene de sepultado
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]